[Music]
we're going to be talking today about
the future of coding with GitHub copilot
and just to kind of get a um a awareness
of things how many of you are um are
using a GitHub co-pilot right now or
have used it awesome awesome that's
great this is really good to see is it
not yes okay all right so we're going to
be talking a little bit about kind of
where we've been and kind of where we're
going to be going so first things first
I'm I'm old um I I've been uh building
for the web since I was like 11 and when
we were doing things you know like 20
plus years
ago it was relatively easy to get
started and build things in HTML as I
did create and I spend a ridiculously
long period of time making this um
accurate Windows 95 image um but you
could you know just open up notepad you
could type in some poorly Speck HTML you
would hope that both uh that things
would work appropriately in both
browsers at the time and you could go um
and so what's happened though is over
time things have become more and more
complex we've made coding tougher for
developers Christopher and I were
talking just earlier before we entered
into this about how you know the process
of of even trying to get young people
started coding Now is really different
than even in the Myspace era where there
was a much easier way for people to
immediately see what they were doing and
what they were building and um you know
at this point even making something
simple like an HTML page is harder
because our JavaScript Frameworks have
Frameworks themselves so the process of
doing what it is that we want to do
we've made it harder on ourselves even
though we claim that we really like to
simplify and as a consequence of this
we've also increase the workload for
developers because now you're not just
trying to build code you're also having
to deploy code and you need to be an
expert in deployments and and how are
these things going to run and it's again
not just one JavaScript framework but
the framework on top of that and it's
okay I want to work with AI but where do
I get started I need to maybe do some
things in front end some things in back
end but am I going we've just we've
really made things uh complicated for
ourselves and we've increased the
workload for developers so when we think
about
what the opportunities are for that at
get we're thinking about how artificial
intelligence AI is the next Frontier for
developer experience there was a
McKenzie study that do you remember when
this came
out I don't okay 223 okay so so 2023
McKenzie found that if you give
developers um that if you basically you
know if they're more productive that's
going to improve the developer
experience and the developers who are
using generative AI tools were more than
twice as likely to report overall
happiness fulfillment and like state of
flow so basically developers who are
using tools like GitHub co-pilot and and
other generative AI assistants can be
more successful because they can comp
they can de complicate and and more
simplify a lot of the processes that we
have to do day in and day out so some of
the examples of this are um some of the
you can spend you know less time having
to write the the the boring tedious code
that we write time and time again that
boilerplate code um having to spend time
doing debugging searching through
documentation um you know trying to
figure out what the existing code that
someone who worked on your team five
years ago and and three generations ago
and and however many management chains
ago created and you're like what was
this it wasn't commented correctly we
don't even use this anymore um you know
fixing syntax problems uh remembering
get commands because look I work at
GitHub I don't remember most git
commands these are all things that are
really really use um great uh use cases
of AI and these are things that co-pilot
can do really really well because these
are things that a there's a lot of
Corpus in out there on the public web
about so the models can be trained on
them and B these are things that can you
can use natural language to ask
questions to really easily and when you
offload that TDM that means that we can
spend more time doing the things we
really like to do so you know
collaborating with one another planning
for new projects iterating on things
we've already built on designing new
features and so that's really kind of
the opportunity it's not so much A lot
of people think oh we're going to be
losing our jobs uh to Ai and okay maybe
I I don't know I'm not you know a
futurist but I really think it's more
like a lot of the things that we do that
we have to do we can uh automate away
which is one of our favorite things to
do as developers anyway and we can
actually spend more time on the harder
problems that we usually have to always
put on the back
burner and so when we think about um Ai
and how we do it at GitHub our our
approach is to have a CO Cod first
approach so we really are thinking about
how can we make um think thinking
forward through code first and so an
example of this is you know the reason
we call it co-pilot is because it's not
doing it for you it is in fact you are
co-pilot you are still in
control sorry no problem so for instance
you can use realtime um you know natural
language to convert a comment to code
which is a great way to do basically use
natural language to say Okay I want to
um you know create a function to parse
the URL and knowing what it knows about
what you've already been writing in your
code what what other files are open it
can do that for you or I want to
generate a scaffold for a you know a
nextjs project these are things that you
can do with a code companion right
now and what's also great is that we
have a chat functionality built in in
addition to being able to do inline um
uh get code suggestions or uh you know
ghost text there's also a component with
GitHub co-pilot chat where you can talk
directly to a chat assistant similar to
chat gbt and ask more specific questions
both about the code you're working on
and about more General things um as well
as using things like agents um that can
come by way of extensions or uh things
that are built into the editor to get
specific context about specific things
so for instance we have a feature in vs
code with co-pilot chat where you can at
workspace and find out all U information
about specific files that are in your
project and you can use one called
terminal if you want to get insights
into terminal so if you're like me and
you don't remember any FFM commands you
can at Terminal and then say help me
write an FFM command to do this and it
will actually give it to you and then
you don't have to go through those Man
pages which is awesome um and uh you can
also use this to debug things create
tests and find out hey this code is
vulnerable can you help me fix this so
these are all great things that you can
do within a chat interface right
now and one of the other things uh to
kind of pivoting on that when we think
about how to make this better because
this is the most frequent question we
get is how can you know I've had I'm
having trouble kind of getting co-pilot
to really work with me we really think
about uh four specific things one
context so you want to provide as much
information as possible to the co-pilot
so that it knows what you're wanting it
to do because it it's not a perfect
system but by being as specific as
possible which is the next thing not
being vague and saying this is what I
want to do exactly like this even giving
examples can go along Long Way um
examples are a fantastic opportunity
because llms are really really good at
pattern matching that's one of the
things they're best at so the more
examples you provide the more specific
you are and the better context about
what you're working on you are the
better it's going to be um and if you
have good code to come in is so if your
examples are of good code itself that
means you're going to get better results
as
well and now we're going to be talking a
little bit about where things can go in
the future Christopher yeah so let's
talk a little bit then about um an AI
first approach so one of the things
about using Code completion or using
chat is that you're going to be doing
that inside your IDE so I'm going to be
writing some code and then it's going to
make um that ghost Tech suggestion I'm
going to accept that I'm going to reject
that I'm going to accept it and and make
some modifications and then keep going
from there or maybe I'm going to go into
chat and then inside of chat I'm going
to highlight a block of code I'm going
to ask it to explain it or I'm going to
give it a particular task but you'll
noce in that scenario that I'm already
inside my IDE that I'm already writing
some code but what happens if maybe
somebody files an issue and they go hey
we want to implement some bit of new
functionality so maybe it's we want to
migrate from JavaScript to typescript I
personally would call that an upgrade
some people get picky about that I call
it there we go we're just we're just
going to call that an upgrade um so I
want to be able to there we go getting
some some thumbs up here I want to be
able to do this and so I know that this
is going to be a very large process that
I don't really want to go in and start
modifying a whole bunch of individual
code files by myself or one of the other
bigger requests is hey we've got some
python 2 code that we need to upgrade or
we've got Cobalt code that we need to go
in and modernize and we know that it's
not going to be possible to completely
automate that but it'd be nice if we
could at least get a jump start it be
nice if the stuff that could be
automated some of that rough translation
if that could be done for us and so what
I can do is I can file an issue and then
go from there the other very big thing
is we've all seen the poll request that
was missing something in particular unit
tests now I know I know I know everybody
in here everybody's perfect about
writing their unit tests we'll go with
that we also docent our code absolutely
and write document
um but believe it or not there are some
teams where people won't do those types
of things so I'm reviewing a poll
request and I realize hey we're missing
testing so what I can then do is as
we'll see in a moment go into my
workpace and go this is what I'm missing
I need unit tests I need whatever it is
that it might be I need documentation
and it will then go ahead and generate
that for me now one very big thing to
keep in mind is that it's going to start
by taking a look at what we've got and
then build out a proposal so in this
particular case this is from an example
and I'll I'll do this live in just a
moment here where we're looking to
upgrade um uh an index.js file into
typescript so it gives me my current
situation so it's looking at the entire
project and going hey this is what I'm
currently seeing so right now you're not
using typescript for this so here's my
proposal we give me the proposal down
below but as we all know this is AI and
AI could wind up making a mistake so
maybe it misses something so maybe it it
got something in the spec wrong or maybe
it it's missing a step on a proposal so
I have an ability to edit it right there
to further clarify and describe what it
is that I'm hoping to have accomplished
then it will go okay so I've got the
spec I've got this proposal now let's
let's go ahead and show you what needs
to be
changed so it will list off then all of
the files that need to be updated for
this so you'll notice that it's going to
tell me it wants to rename it and do all
of this now from here I can also again
add on some more additional steps so if
I wanted to create interfaces if I
wanted to import particular libraries uh
maybe update my Dev contain or not my
Dev container my uh package Json file um
with uh some additional types Imports
then I can go ahead and add that in
right there and then finally once I look
at that and I go hey that looks good I
then Implement my selected
files and then now it will generate all
of the updated code for me now one very
important thing here is that the goal is
not replacing the developer the goal is
augmenting the developer so from here
it's then going to generate code I am
not going to inherently just trust
anything that is generated by AI now let
me back this up let's think about how we
wrote code before we had access to
generative AI so I would write some code
based on my own knowledge I would write
some code copied and pasted from stack
Overflow that I would modify and just
kind of hope and pray that it might
actually
work and then I would also copy and
paste code from document ation but
here's the thing is that throughout all
of that process I'm also going to have
devops to back that up that I'm going to
have a human go in and review my code
I'm going to have linters I'm gonna have
IP scans I'm gonna have Security checks
I'm going to do all of those different
things with all of the code even the
code that I've written because
apparently I don't always write perfect
code which was a surprise but here we
are so I always want to make sure that
I'm validating that and the same thing
holds true here is that I want to
validate this code so I'm going to
review all of this code right here and
make sure that all of that looks good
and we'll also see that I'll be able to
open that up inside of a code space and
have access to a full Editor to be able
to edit this now some considerations
number one I think we talked an awful
lot about this already but keeping the
developer in the loop so treat this code
and this is true universally with
co-pilot all up but treat that code just
like any other code that you would have
created via any other mechanism also
what's great about a workspace is that
this will now become available
effectively as as a web page so I can
then share this out with the rest of my
team so if I create a poll request from
this I can actually have the link to the
workspace so that way my other teammates
can go in and take a look at this I can
explore prototypes this is not going to
be modifying code in place so I can
create a brand new Branch I can create a
uh a poll request from this now what I
really love this for is being able to do
project wide changes so one of the
conversations I was having a little bit
earlier is let's say that I'm using
typescript and I realize hey I want to
create an interface then I want to
update a whole bunch of files to start
using that interface now I can ask for
co-pilot to to help me out an awful lot
with that today and what it will do is
if I'm using like the um the the little
this is such an overloaded word right
now um the outwork space command inside
of chat this is not this um agent yeah
the agent there we go uh that I can
actually have it look through the entire
project and go hey these are all the
places where I think you should be
putting in that interface but it's not
going to modify those files
automatically for me this can then make
those modifications so it looks a little
like this microphone yes um do you want
us to talk or do you want me to no I
mean so go all right so this right here
this is a Django app right I'm going no
okay so yeah this okay we're gonna be
updating the typescript application okay
so first thing we're going to be doing
is we're going to be opening this up in
a workspace so this is um a a GitHub
co-pilot
workspaces and it's in preview if this
fails this is in preview live demo we're
praying to the demo Gods please please
be with us okay all right so you've got
your workspace open and this is your
plan this is what your what we already
talked about what you want to do okay
and this is what the proposal is so now
we're going to generate that plan and
it's going to say all right we want to
do all these things and does this look
good are you gonna want to add anything
or remove anything from the plan
actually you know what I'm gonna go back
up here real quick I'm going
to um um update um uh the uh readme to
include build steps now you have that
one too awesome
um okay okay which is great it's a great
thing to update the readme great to be
um thinking about documentation
reproducibility good job Christopher
your future team um thanks you all right
so now we're creating the plan and it's
going to give us a spec of all the
things that you need to
do just like that yep and so it's making
edits to two different files here right
so it's making it um editing you know
changing the the JS file to typescript
and then it's actually
um proposing um some changes to the
readme file as
well all right so now we're going to
implement this and all right come on
demo
gods and it's working and actually it's
working pretty well um going pretty fast
they actually pushed out an update real
recently it goes much faster now well
that's good that's good again SL preview
works really well when we're doing live
demos like this the team the team is
very happy that we are doing these sorts
of things um not at all scared about
what what it will do for the public
perception all right so now this is
going to give us an idea of what sorts
of in our two different files what
changes are being made and so we can see
the diff right here you can actually
edit the diff if if you want um but if
you're anything like me and I know I am
I
actually thank you um I actually want an
editor and so you'll notice right up
here I have open in codes space give
this a moment to spin up a code space
and if you're not already familiar with
code spaces they're the best they are
it's probably my my one of my like
favorite little features that I don't
think we talk enough about um it's a
cloud-based environment for me to write
code and what's great about them is that
basically you can predefine your
dependencies and what versions you have
of various things so it's set up exactly
for what you need on your project so
it's no longer works on my machine it's
as long as you have access to a
codespace it'll work everywhere and it's
basically the same as the visual studio
code interface but it's going to take
place in a web browser although you can
also open up a code space in jet brains
or in Visual Studio code locally if you
want to do that too all right so now
keep vamping apparent I was going to say
I was going to say this is taking a
little bit longer this is where our our
our demo might take more time but in the
meantime you can still if you did want
to make edits in the the workspace UI
you could um and so we're looking
through now what the different edits are
how does this look looks good to me okay
let's see is this there it is hey look
at that yep so it's even updated the
readme file which is great yep so it
made the update to my read and here we
go yeah this is the code space now and
you can see that even in the code space
these changes are coming in and so you
don't have to worry about I don't know
if I want to use you know the the
non-intuitive editor can use the the
tools that you're familiar with as
well cool and by the way you can still
have all of your extensions inside of
here um so that way if you've got like
the spell checker um which I personally
appreciate yeah
um yeah and so you'll also notice the
little buttons down below now we're
going to be able to create a poll
request just like anything else and so
what this is going to do is actually
going to do one of the best things now I
don't know about you when I write PLL
requests usually they're not very
descriptive and they say things like fix
bug and then two seconds later no no for
real please work and and and so this
time is actually going to give them a
title which is more indicative of what
this is which is update index.js to
typescript and then the description is
going to be a natural language um
explanation of what we are accomplishing
now again like all AI things some of
these things are going to be accurate
sometimes it might get things wrong so
you might need to make some
modifications but you know what it's
better than nothing which is what a lot
of us do now yep so here we go this is
our poll request and we can also this oh
this is new Co pilot can help you review
this poll request this is an alpha
things move fast neither of us had seen
this we hadn't this is Alpha so we can
get feedback on this okay we're not
going to get into this right now talk to
us at the booth actually
seriously we don't know how this works
so I mean we could you want to try it
let's try it sure why not let's try it
why not this is this is new for us
too exactly what's the worst that could
happen it could break and we'll just
have to pretend that we didn't do this
but you know what if you come talk to us
in the booth um we've got some um
members of the the workspaces team who
might be able to show other things here
we go so this is opening up a chat
context yeah so this is now going to
allow us to chat with this poll request
and I guess I guess the idea is if we
want to get more information that is
cool this is actually very
cool yeah and we're and and
what you're see live reaction
reac where this would really be useful
I'm just guessing this this is the
intent because again I didn't know about
this until about two minutes ago um is
if you are if you're usually I'm not
going to be reviewing my own poll
request yeah
so if I'm reviewing something that you
did and co-pilot is now going to say hey
do you want do you want my help and I
mean because the other thing is like
when I go to like files strange like the
this diff screen is not is not really
overly helpful um and so it can like
really take a a long time here let's see
is it still G to be it's not right here
um how do I get that back come back ask
co-pilot yay there you go um yeah and so
what I really love is like it's already
pointing me at the difference spots that
I might want to um might want to review
that's cool my Cally just asked will
itest and heed
out now now now you back and be like
actually as have an hour ago it will yes
that's cool all right um the other real
quick thing I want to highlight because
of the fact that this is a poll request
that it did in fact go in and um and run
my unit test because I have an action
set up for it to run unit test so it's
actually running all of that telling me
right now I'm missing coverage we'll go
back and we'll write unit test later so
but yeah I think that's our 20 we've
gotone 22 minutes now does
to C
mention oh oh right now no that that
that they we're still try figure that
out however there is a terminal that you
can pull up in workspace is not going to
be the same thing but but that is uh
frequent feedback continue as as this is
still in preview give us more feedback
on that because we're going to be
looking at how we can make the
experiences more
uniform no you're not wrong I I honestly
when I'm coding I'm kind of in a similar
situation so um we're looking for
feedback on this and and we've got a
couple members of our of our team who
are in the booth who can talk a little B
more about this awesome beautiful
great well this is what we've got time
for um do we have um all right continue
to experiment train your developers
collaborate please comment your code for
so many reasons yeah for so many reasons
um we will be in the booth uh the
Microsoft Booth if you have more
questions and be a to show off more
demos this was fun we I didn't know that
we were going to be seeing a new feature
neither did I that's the best there we
go thank you so much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]